thank you
hot breath
I've been waiting on this for a long
time this is it man this is it
we out here
so we're just gonna do um
and we're doing a live podcast here
because we got a hot breath alum
uh Mr Alton Walker in here
we out here live audience could you take
a photo of us too man it's for
documentation
but uh this is this is for you my man
you got a little hop recorder for you
okay all right
I'm gonna do a little bit yeah yeah
this is a fontus water this is our water
sponsor there okay Georgia Mountain
spring water
with the hot breath labels
all right hot brother verse we got a
good one coming to you today this is a
one of a kind guest right here this
gentleman is not only the son of
Superstar comedian Ricky Smiley but he's
also a comedian in his own right started
comedy way back at the age of seven till
the age of 13 took a break now after um
couple entrepreneurial Endeavors and
jail experiences rehab experiences he's
now hopping back into the game so if you
enjoy this please hop right the verse be
sure to share this with your other
comedian hot Brethren and sister and uh
if you do want us to rise the charts on
iTunes and support us head on over to
iTunes just give us a quick five star
review and we appreciate you so
without further Ado please welcome to
the hot breath the verse the one and
only Mr Brandon Smiley ladies and
gentlemen oh y'all how y'all doing Mr
Joe my man how are you sir yo thanks for
doing this and this is a very funny guy
by the way all right this man he got
like that dry humor that's funny as hell
I like the [__] I don't know if you can
cause conversation yeah you say whatever
you want okay cool man cool yeah yeah
yeah let it out pretty funny guy right
here man for real right you're funny too
my man thank you man how long you been
back in the game uh two years now two
years yes sir what brought you back uh
everybody tell them I need to do it like
I was just on Facebook just making
random statuses and my status was
getting like hundreds of hundreds of
likes and shares and
my dad was like man you need to go on
stage my mom's saying the same thing my
mom and dad don't agree on anything no
it was pretty amazing so I guess there
was a sign from God yeah won't he do it
he'll do it so when you jumped in at the
age of seven first off what was that
push and what was that whole experience
it was weird um my dad had this uh this
comedy club called a cobblestone it was
in Birmingham Alabama and one day he was
getting ready to go to work and I was at
home my brothers and sister and I was
like uh I want to do comedy and he was
like you want to do it tonight I was
like yeah so on the way to the club he
wrote me a couple of like little
one-liners on a piece of paper and he
told me to read and I took the paper on
stage with me and I read it and uh you
know it went pretty good and after that
I started doing it for like seven to
seven years oh man any uh any epic bombs
in those early years oh
a child bombing is I think I think I got
kind of booed by like a section of
people okay then I cracked on the person
even though I didn't see him I was like
your mom got one eye and one lid they
call it Eileen yeah so I kind of saved
myself then I ended the show right there
so I was like 10 years old when I did
that so 18 years old yeah I'd have some
awkward moments on stage yo what was the
most awkward
oh I had did like a uh this was like a
year ago I was at the stardome in
Birmingham Alabama and I did a uh this
was after elections and um during the
election one of the issues was uh
abortions and I had did an abortion joke
and it didn't go well you know if you're
gonna be offensive you're gonna do an
offensive joke it got to be really funny
and like one white guy was like in the
back he was just like
it was just weird man no then I never
did that joke again
oh
good oh well I got uh boo then I came
back on stage and the rest of the show
was just weird I try not to have bad
shows I try to be if I feel myself
having a bad show I kind of try to make
it go kind of high paced like
so I can just get them to laugh laugh
and you know just uh get in and get out
basically
oh yeah I can rock it I can rock it
but when the guy booze you do you say
anything to him how do you really oh
someone bad it was just weird uh-huh
I didn't really have a comeback I kind
of I kind of laughed it off uh
kind of it's kind of awkward it's like
an awkward moment man but uh have you
ever had one oh man I've been booed at a
place called taboo I've uh I mean I had
a lady flash me on stage before like
I've been through the mud and that
sounds amazing that sounds good well let
me see that are you calling me
Oh no you're good no we out here
oh you're letting me know you're here
okay
well what uh what made you quit when you
were 13. when I was 13 and I quit I
didn't really have any content no I was
the son of a celebrity I haven't visited
I ain't really having any content my
life was kind of boring I was getting
picked up by my nanny from school I have
[__] to talk about so I just had to grow
up I had to go through stuff I had to
deal with family issues had a day go
through bad breakups I had to be broke I
had to sleep in the car a couple of
nights I had to go through stuff with my
family and I have to learn and just get
get good content you know you you you
you have
um communism is a lot about being
relatable you know people can relate to
you even if the Jokers have fun and you
can probably you can probably win them
over so I just had to get something
relatable
things I had to you know get a couple of
loans and uh well wait you had to get a
couple loans you said what what is This
Hold on shut up the Easy Money Hold on I
still owed them 60 right now I'm gonna
pay y'all mine as soon as they pay me oh
it's sixty dollars no it was more than
that about um I paid on the loan oh okay
yeah so oh I got a 60 balance right I
got a 60 balance right now I'm gonna pay
that when uh the uh yeah to pay me so
what wait hold on let's let's let's
rewind a little bit what is the son of
Ricky Smiley doing sleeping in a car and
taking out loans okay uh loan stores uh
I went to Alabama State okay the Hornets
yeah all right what you know about
Alabama State we out here okay okay
we'll have to get him a black card real
soon real soon I'll go to Alabama State
and um my dad was just investing all
this money into my first semester and I
came on I think I made like straight
else
and he like withdrew me out of school he
like blocked me and I just had the fan
for myself you know so I had to end up
getting a a hotel for a couple days and
a couple I couldn't afford a hotel so
like one night it was in a couple night
I always answer right it was one that I
had to sleep in the car and it was like
cold in Montgomery Alabama outside of a
hotel like this is a true story
and um
after that I took my ass back home to
Birmingham
pretty much packed my [__] and uh yeah
man it had some rough time well he
accepted you back no no I want to go
stay at my grandmother's house yo yeah
so what where was where was Ricky at in
his career like was he on on yeah he's
been on here since I was like
my dad's been going harder since I was
like [__] nine dude so like what yo yeah
I guess that's just tough love is that
yeah my dad oh my dad tough love man
when I was growing up
no my dad had a big ass yo like a
commercial style yard this is a
Millionaire's yard so we had to cut
grass and
and
um
you know uh rebuild the transmission on
the car yeah the car and messed up if
you believe that uh
no I'm just playing but yeah he uh he he
always showed tough love man we got we
got we was beaten growing up you know we
didn't we rarely got them put on we was
beating the end played on punishment oh
word yeah it wasn't one of the other and
you get a whipping in my house and it
didn't get put on punishment what was
the worst the worst whipping yeah yeah
oh you got to stay in frame for this one
too oh yeah okay you gotta stay tight
stay in it I'm with you right now
Brandon let's do this the worst whooping
I ever had oh my dad bought me a
slingshot okay yeah we were staying at
Center Point Alabama and um in the back
of our house we had like this playground
it was like two stores where you can go
on top and you slide down and on the
other side of the fence cars could drive
by
so when I had a slingshot uh I thought
of the bright idea to get some rocks and
basically aim at cars
and basically bust the windows and my
friend little brother
snitched on me and told my dad
and I told my dad no and he walked
outside and it was glass on the street
and he was like if you didn't do it then
watch the glass in the street long story
short I I got one of the worst ass
weapons oh how long did it lasts oh I
don't know good
good 40 seconds it was an intense 40
seconds oh yeah
my worst ass whooping didn't come from
my dad came from my mom word yeah I used
to yeah my mom used to my mom didn't
play it um
sounds like neither of them didn't hell
no I used to grab the belt when my mom
used with me and she would like uh hit
my knuckles with the belt buckle to give
me to Let It Go hell yeah my mama didn't
[__] play I guess they have that in
common your parents do yeah tough love
but it made me the man I am today you
know being on punishment a lot a lot
like uh it made me the man I am today
because now I can just uh I can sit in
the hole myself for hours I was gonna
say you've been to jail before
a couple times yeah I love how cool you
just said that now I've been a couple
times you know we a little stent yeah
just a couple little stuff here and
there what what was it drinking uh no I
ain't gonna do it drinking but yeah man
I gotta uh have some extents with the
Lord like not showing all the cord and
stuff but uh dealing with marijuana and
uh things of that nature
and now you're you're clean living now
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm clean I
don't do drugs at all you know I smoke a
little weed every now and then all right
when I wake up when I go to sleep yeah
but no hard stuff no drugs no pills
cocaine hey did you went to rehab yeah
alcohol and all that yeah you bounced
back from all that yeah
so I'm what I'm a little I've heard
like I mean I've done a lot of
interviews with people who have toured
with Ricky and um it's all been just
like secondhand stories but I've heard
there can be a little bit of a temper
with uh with Ricky no yeah I mean yeah
that runs in the family he has a temper
but people uh people have a tendency to
try my dad and my dad's a stand-up guy
like he's a he's a man for real like you
can't play with him if you don't know
him even if you do know him you gotta
want him before you play with him like a
lot of people like think that he's a
comedian they can just say and do
whatever and shoot them in a kind of way
and he don't have a temper he just
stands his ground you know he was raised
by his granddad you know and I was
raised by my dad so that's in all of us
we don't really play the piano you know
we joke we love we give we're humble but
um
re read demand respect
so how is your relationship now that
you're back in the comedy game we're
good me and my dad good actually um he
put me on the show
um Saturday and uh actually two shows
one is at the Buckhead Theater and we're
leaving the bucket theater and doing
another show that night in New Orleans
so yeah he's throwing them a couple of
Bones dang man yeah just pretty cool
yeah yeah pretty cool like growing up
and he's with your dad on the road then
you grow up man you're actually on the
road yourself you know what I'm saying
so it's just it's kind of pretty cool I
guess I guess you get a kick out of it I
guess you would if your son's doing the
same stuff you're doing and it's halfway
decent at it
what have you learned from the in the
comedy game what have you learned um
just relax and uh don't let the crowd
eat you up just be confident have high
energy and uh try not to be a bully and
talk about people I don't really talk
about people at my shows okay you know I
try not to pull the crowd away from me
you know I just trying to just be funny
and have high energy and work on my
timing and and be professional as I can
be
so how do you relax because that's
something a lot of comics struggle with
is you can yeah
I Pace back and forth before my show
that's how I relax take deep breaths
Pace uh I don't drink uh or do anything
if I go on stage because it blurs my
mind
um I'm just trying to pace and pray
she used to pray before every show I
asked God to um make me have a good show
if you don't have God on your side you
don't have anything right okay you gotta
have God on your side yeah let him use
it all all the time you should come by
the room man I'll tell you about Jesus
come by the room let's talk about Jesus
where's the room Best Western Best
Western oh you got it like that oh yeah
man oh man started from the car now
we're here oh yeah we gotta
but it's cool like you you seem to have
earned it the hard way which is like the
right way where you appreciate wherever
you are now right right when I started
my um me and my dad was on uh kind of
okay turn
um we had kind of like fell out like uh
shortly after I started and um me and my
dad got a career relationship sometimes
we good sometimes we're not and
sometimes my fault sometimes it's his
fault but that's here not there but um
yeah man I don't perform like something
everywhere like I don't even performed
in barbershops before a lot of people
don't know that what yeah yeah I'm in
the barber shop before like a barbershop
had like a little uh like a talent show
and my friend comedian
um
he told me about it and I went
and uh I actually did it was pretty cool
actually was there a microphone yeah
it's a microphone it's a microphone and
everything people's getting their
haircuts
real talk it was pretty cool though like
uh it humbles you just yeah you're just
starting out doing stuff like that
instead of just throwing out doing sold
out crowds and stuff like that that way
you know when I eventually get sold out
shows maybe I'd appreciate it a little
more and be more humble about it oh yeah
dude I've done shows on like sidewalks
and like patios and pretty low man I
don't think I'd do that yo that's the
grind man yeah man I mean you're only
two years in you're like man I got
Buckhead Theater I'm like a word I've
seen it before
yeah yeah that's what's up man for real
that's like that's determination yeah I
love oh dude I love comedy yeah that's
why I was like gravitated towards you
because I was like you started at seven
yeah man like I mean I used to own it's
crazy I just get kicked out of school
for this and like uh I just get a kid
out of school so much and my teacher
know I did come and she made a deal with
me like if I didn't get in trouble all
day she'll let me do a joke at the end
of class I swear to God every time
before I uh do the job I call my dad
like uh nah I did good today you got a
joke for me he'll give me a little joke
I mean when the first joke I actually
remember the first joke I did
yeah I mean the first joke I did yeah
the first joke I did I was like uh what
do fat good people
eat how do fat people eat this cereal
and then the current the uh classroom
was like how and I was like out of a
Super Bowl and this is like super bowl
like the weekend you know the Super Bowl
oh perfect yeah I killed I killed that I
killed where the fat people yeah how do
they eat cereal yeah okay you still do
that one no no okay how old were you
about nine maybe that was nine you're
doing it in class yeah you did it in
class okay dude that's crazy get out
doing stand-up I like I know a lot of
comedians we we think about wanting to
do comedy but it took me to like senior
year of college when I'm like well I
don't have anything else to lose lost
all my money so I might as well try
comedy right but the fact you took the
leap at seven man right that's uh that's
a prayer I appreciate it man I mean it's
not The Express of me man a lot of kids
are doing um
been a kid singers and kid actors and
stuff you just gotta oh no you just
gotta uh swallow your swallow your fear
and just get out there well what's
what's the uh what's the vision now
because you're you're 28 now yeah so
you've been back in the game like two
years right so I mean you have a manager
already this early in and uh who booked
this gig by the way oh yeah shout out to
T Dog so um
so like what is I mean you clearly
you've got a team around you you're
still young in the game in terms of like
comedy years like what is what is your
vision how are you making moves right
now man I'm just um taking any and every
opportunity in this donut that man just
taking everything and going with it you
know um it's not all about the money
right now for real just about the
opportunity you know so I'm just trying
to get as many opportunities as I can
man be more uh more uh
blah blah blah blah more successful you
know get paid more for a show yeah you
know once I start getting like you know
like at least ten thousand a show yeah
then I think I'd be pretty successful
but I think
and uh be looking out for weave Kings
yes it's a move I'm Ryan
um oh you're riding a movie yeah oh yeah
you got sponsors for it and everything
okay
it's called weed King basically these
two guys
who basically own nothing gonna be best
friends or brothers but they um grew up
together and they came they got this
horrible job and they came across a box
of weave which is hair you know we just
oh yeah Virgin Remy and yeah
we got to get your black car for real we
woke we won't get my manager on that
immediately
um and basically they come across all
this hair and they didn't know what it
was um they didn't really think nothing
of it until a girl came over seeing it
then they started selling the hair and
it's just silly as hell like it's silly
like the whole movie's gonna be just
silly as hell you haven't shot it yet no
we're still running well if you needed
some salt to that pepper let me know I
got you we out here man I got you bro
okay yeah you're writing a movie only
two years back into this game you're
touring around
doing Buckhead Theater and all this
other cool stuff like right I'm even
thinking of you just growing up the way
you did you've probably met some cool oh
yeah and maybe gotten game along the way
as well like what are some of those
experiences you could being cool as hell
man I've never been a person get
Starstruck because I uh you know I I try
not to you know I meant like Mike Epps
uh I've been to Steve Harvey's house uh
I seen Chris tuck I met Chris Tucker one
time I met the Rock
that's that's the only time I've been
Starstruck when I met the rock like the
rock doing Johnson and I was Starstruck
when I met him um Morgan Freeman just
just a couple of people wait what was
take us back to that rock moment man my
dad was hosting the NAACP Awards he took
me and my god sister uh with him and he
was going down the red carpet and that's
the I'm looking down the Carver and it's
it's the freaking Rock like The Rock
Dwayne Johnson like uh can you smell
what The Rock cooking Dwayne Johnson and
uh we took pictures with him and
everything he cool dude man he's like
he's in real life but um it was like
definitely one of the most memorable
parts of my life take us to Steve
Harvey's House
please break down that whole experience
because this guy like what what's crazy
about like the the comedians at that
level where it's comedians doing more
than just comedy which I mean which is a
goal of mine but like using their comedy
is almost a a launch pad to make even a
greater impact like people like Steve
Harvey like people like your dad has
done right so like you being in the
environment with someone like Steve
Harvey being in his domain at his house
like what what did you learn from that
or what was that experience and what
kind of impact did it have on you
um it was pretty cool like it just
showed me that you can um if you do
right you can do basically anything
that's possible like just in the house
with Steve Harvey uh it was one weekend
um my dad was staying in Texas uh this
was still Steve Harvey has a house in
Texas I don't know if he still had a
house or not but um Steve Harvey invited
me and my dad over and he got like a
garage full of like four wheelers and
dirt bikes and stuff so he got a lot of
land too so he went around dirt bikes
and all that and we came back another
time and Steve Harvey cooked dinner for
us
swear to God
I was so nervous I ain't even eat the
dinner Steve Harvey was like do you want
something like no sir I'm good he's like
you sure I'm like uh yes sir I'm good
and when we got me when my me and my dad
got back in the car my dad he was like
stupid fool next time Steve Harvey offer
you something to eat you know you take
it you know but uh next time I go over
it I'm definitely going to um
eat eat the cake wait he actually hit
you was he actually angry yeah
[Music]
how old were you when this was happening
I don't know like 12 13. no no I'm like
like 14. did uh did he bestow any wisdom
or game no and I was just listening to
him it was just talking I'm just
listening to him talk just watching
learning from them you know but I
learned a lot of stuff uh I learned most
of my stuff like from the like as far as
the coming game goes just from um
smaller going on the road my dad about
how he conducted himself how he handling
his business how um how to handle
certain situations and that kind of like
I feel like gave me a head start on the
game as well because I've been around I
already know the tricks and what to look
out for and all it is how to handle
certain people and um it really teach
you a lot just growing up around that
like you imagine like if you if your dad
worked at McDonald's you went to his job
every day watching flipbergs
[__] when you work go to work
for McDonald's
so yeah so I'm pretty much up on it
yeah let it a lot of people that listen
to this are like comedians out on the
grind right so give it give us a little
more detail into like the specific
things you may have learned with like
being with your dad on the road
you know it's not just about the show
you know the business aspect you know
just always try to be professional as
you can you know and the word
extraordinaire you know that's the
ordinary but it's also the extra just
basically going above and beyond just
trying to set set the uh
be above the standard you know what I'm
saying because everybody's fun a lot of
people's funny you know what I'm saying
but it's and we got a lot of competition
out here and you know that especially in
Atlanta like it's it's filled with uh
Comedians and stuff so you can't just be
fun anyway that's the easy part being
funny what are you doing what else are
you doing like the business what are you
doing behind the scenes and all that
stuff like you equate into the right
math equation like you can you can be
pretty successful
so doing stuff Beyond just like stand up
right it's really only one degree of it
right and how you conduct business like
how you show up like the way you dress
like I always try to dress nice you know
what I'm saying look like you're the
haircut you know what I'm saying don't
cuss too much you know what I'm saying
you don't turn the crowd off you know
how to handle hecklers and all this
stuff and um just growing up watching
all this stuff man it really helped me
out today
and it I'm sure gives you a little bit
of a competitive advantage and and also
a lot of times as comedians like it took
me a while to start thinking bigger you
know what I mean like in terms of like
well I'll just do the open mics and just
grind it out and just dude which is part
of the process but I'm at a point in my
career where I'm in the growth mindset
of like oh well there's way more
possibilities than meet the eye
initially where I was just like I'll
just be a comedian and maybe make a
living but now I'm like no I want to
make like an impact right right so where
is your mindset because I mean you're
only two years back into it but you
growing up in this environment that it's
like oh I'm seeing the one percent of
Comedy right now like I'm in like the
rare realm of people who have really
made an international impact so like
where is your mindset and what you're
wanting to do with this comedy game
man what I want to do with it just uh
like not uh what I want to do with the
coming game
I just want to rock it man I want to be
good at what I do man I don't really
have anything specific to answer that
but I just want to be good I want to be
genuinely funny you know what I'm saying
like I want to be able to Rock shows
like you ever uh
went on uh after a comedian that like
did like good like oh you ever been uh
at any kind of made you feel a certain
type of way about going on after and he
ever been in a a dead show like where
the crowd was really feeling but she was
opening up for a headliner and you know
that the headline every time he comes
out there no matter what the crowd
how the crowd is they Rock the show yes
and I'm just trying to get to that point
like comedians like sir Walt uh Julie
Scoggins uh uh Godfrey um that's just a
number of people I've opened up for man
you put them in front of anybody man
they're gonna rock the show period some
days my days be kind of off like
depending on the audience you know but
I'm getting better at that and that's
the point where I'm trying to get to
well I'm rocking that [__] regardless
yeah like The Undefeated right right
yeah I just did a show like Sunday and
uh Alton Walker was there and every
comedian went up ate it and then the
headliner gets up there and just just
kills it for 45 minutes like just it's
just having that extra gear where when
the audience isn't giving you the energy
back you almost like exercise it from
them right right it's just stage time
really right yeah people be doing that
uh that uh can do it like that but in
the game for like 15 plus years exactly
you got to give it to him man that's a
long ass time to be doing this
long time you can learn a lot from doing
it if you've been doing it this long
you're not at that level then you're
doing something wrong because I'm trying
to beat everybody like in the next two
years and you're really only two years
in right into the game you got to think
that's almost like if you think of
Comedy is like a language two years in
man it's like you're like Google gaga
right right now you know and even like
you know I'm almost nine years in and
I'm still like there's sometimes I'm
like yeah I got it and then like the
show Sunday I'm like oh man I'm still
here right right it's comedy always has
a way she always keeps you humble right
right you're feeling yourself as good as
your last show yeah that's right that's
um if I have I hate in a weekend on a
bad show and it's just my nerves all
week yeah yeah I like to just run dude
that's why at home like my last show
like use on Sunday I try to rock that
[__] out so I give you some sleep that
week right right now I ain't never got
boo but if I if I have a not enough I
would but if I know it's coming
that's why I asked you because like I
ask all my guests like what is your
worst Booth story not [__] man yeah that
little boo in the back you haven't had
those yeah yeah yeah just one guy was
like it was just awkward like boom it
was just weird
hasn't happened yet nothing would again
that's my favorite yeah I don't know how
we'll handle that that's like one of my
worst fears like oh yeah it's getting
better how do you come out of it like
just getting booed on that level
you just bounce back this [__] happened
to you seen that last night took an air
over tonight
he's keeping keep tabs on that you need
that immediately
but um the only Community I've seen like
really bounce back or something like
that you seen uh Bill Burr you seen that
that that time he got booed and feeling
yeah and he just ripped the crown for
like 10 minutes straight yeah yeah and
there was like one that's like one of my
favorite videos but that like I don't I
couldn't do that like he did it but like
yeah that's one of my worst fears but
that's that's a dude who's been in the
game right who can fight back you know
what I mean
oh no that's yours you're you're on hot
breath you're the only one that gets to
have breath water my man
he was missing that's good right it's
good
so what I mean you one thing you
mentioned was doing uh right in the
right in the movie right or where else
or what other kind of things do you want
to kind of check off the list oh
I want to get a non-profit you know I'm
trying to help homeless [__] like that
yeah stuff like that like get back to
the community
you know stuff like that uh by my
grandma's house maybe I don't know but
just as far as like in general just open
up a non-profit organization just get
back like kids and homeless people
because this cold is [__] outside yeah
like it's cold as [__] like for real for
real and there's people out there ain't
got a roof over their hand ain't got hit
in the house it's people like freezing
to death in Chicago right now so if I
can just put together a program that's
uh get sponsored maybe by the state or
even myself or maybe a fellow comedian
it just makes your homeless people have
a warm place to stay
overnight you know what I'm saying just
yeah because that's no excuse man this
country has too much money in order for
it to be homeless people on the street
freezing to death why is that so
um personal to you why isn't that
personal to everybody that's the that's
the question the the the the fact that
you have to ask that that's the problem
with the world today but it's personal
I'm gonna tell you why a person with me
because you got to think bigger than
yourself if you're you only if you're
accepting you're thinking about yourself
then
you know what I'm saying you got to put
other people before yourself sometimes
and uh it just humbles you man just to
be able to help people
you know um plus I'm trying to trying to
get into heaven
oh is that that's the long-term game
that's it you're like you're what's
wrong with the world man you know I'm
just trying to get in there you know
what I mean you know but I was just
aside man yeah yeah man uh yeah I just
want to be good at what I do man be able
to help somebody okay better bless
somebody like my like my dad wasn't like
he helped people a lot like uh a lot of
times people don't even know about like
helping kids get cars who don't have
transportation and
send them Christmases for for
um children don't get nothing for
Christmas kids don't wake up with [__]
man imagine do you imagine that and he
helped help with program he got programs
like Dan I just wanted to do stuff like
that you know what I'm saying as well as
the company okay yeah that's what I was
getting at is like where that influence
came from to not be because I mean at
your age you're still young so it can be
easy to get very self-interested and not
think about others you know right right
but we've been like that like our whole
life like we didn't we never had big
Christmases like every Christmas morning
me my dad and my family go out and give
it to other people like we go out to the
individual houses and distribute
presence to the family wow right so we
don't really focus on ourselves during
Christmas you know just just trying to
teach us to think to think outside of
ourselves yeah that makes sense no that
does make sense yeah yeah that's wise
man yeah
well uh but before we get out of here
man
um is there anything else you want the
world to know or any more game you could
spit before we get off here oh
[__] oh
no man just live right he has to drink
water
I don't know fontus water yeah drink
Pontius water drink this water right
here it's very very refreshing and thank
you this guy's funny guy like I said
appreciate it Joe man for having me on
here Brandon man no doubt man yeah I
appreciate you man I'm a problem I'm
excited that we're doing the show
together and then I was like what and
then when we talked last night you're
like I started at seven I was like oh it
is in the genetics right you start at
seven but then a long time has passed
and now you're trying you're not trying
you are back in it right it's you know
it's two years in man it's still early
in the game but seems like you have a
two years in you know I'm just like
doing open mics but you have like a
manager and like a bigger vision and I
think that's valuable for comedians to
hear because
with how the world is set up now with
like the internet and social media is
that you can you can't create your own
success and faster right as long as you
have that vision and it seems like that
you could almost be a template for other
comedians to follow in that sense right
right and it's kind of hard to uh like
especially like old school communities
to get like
um because the competition is crazy with
social media because like anybody can be
a comedian now and you don't have to go
on stage right you know what I'm saying
like the only thing you gotta do is just
learn how to edit videos and people
figure out how to edit videos make fun
of videos and then all of a sudden that
comedian which I'm not hustling not
gonna Hustle but like that term comedian
like getting on that stage man like
there's no edit button on there and like
you can't take anything back you can't
rewind right once you're up there you're
up there and that's not comedian status
for me but like yeah that's that that's
social media man that's like real big
that's like changing the game
yeah but how important is the team also
because yeah I've just not recently been
more mindful of like who I surround
myself with and like people I'm
connecting with and how we can help each
other grow together right right how
important is the team for you that's
important to me because you gotta uh
surround yourself with people that's
bringing things to the table yes instead
of just taking stuff from it um I had to
get a manager because I had to get
somebody to find somebody that knows
something that I don't know because I
don't know everything and if you're
humbling up to admit that then you're
you're gonna be okay but like um
I just basically had to get somebody to
think while I'm asleep you know just
thinking of just constantly thinking
this because I have 80d man I can get up
in the morning I'll be on my Facebook
for like two hours before I decide to
even get out the bed so as long as you
got somebody like thinking while you're
sleeping bringing something to the table
and then helping you the things and
you're bouncing ideas off of each other
it's like a team thing you know what I'm
saying if Tom Brady can't win the Super
Bowl by himself you got to have help
yeah and um that's what I have uh got a
team of dedicated individuals that's
willing to help me you know I'm saying
it's all in there that's about their
business and about their hustle
everybody in my team is about their
hustle we're about money we're about
success we're about doing the right
thing we're doing it the right way and
so that's what's that's how important
having a team is to me
yo Brandon Smiley Joe what's your last
name buyers Joel Joel Byers buyers
buyers Joel Byers Joel Byers hot breath
podcast yeah hi bro podcast so I'm
looking forward to seeing the climb man
you're you're early on in the game
you're already making big waves so I
think this is gonna be a a nice time
capsule of the next time we do one of
these man I feel like it's going to be
on something special yeah yeah we're
gonna probably be but we'll probably be
on the top of the end who knows where
we've been a couple of years you know
we'll probably have our own green rooms
right now we're in a conference room
yeah we're in a conference room but um
we're gonna have our own Green Room next
time we do this right my man well
Brandon Smiley thanks for doing this
buddy no problem man all right hot
brother verse you heard it right here my
man Brandon Smiley get yourself a team
surround yourself with people that care
about what you do and that can bring
some of the table instead of taking it
away that's right and be about your
business all right it's show business so
surround yourself with people if your
strength of the show surround yourself
with people whose strength is the
business but all in all this guy right
here you just heard on here is young in
the game but he's making veteran moves
that I hope you can learn from and apply
to yourself so if you have any questions
or you want to reach out to him where
where can they keep up with you oh you
can find them on Facebook as Brandon my
name is Brandon Smiley just search
Brandon smiling um and you can find me
on Instagram BJ smiley19 nothing like
[__] BJ but it's Brandon I'm not gay
okay so BJ smiley 1990.
um
let's get him a better Instagram please
the manager's like oh man he's gotta
pause every time he says his Instagram
yeah man I didn't think that went
through
she's smiling
Reach Out reach out to him or reach out
to us at hot breathpod or at Joel Byers
comment on all social media
joelbyerscommy.com all I ask for you to
do if you want to get merch it'll be
linked in the show notes but all you
gotta do is share this with your fellow
comedians let them know that hot breath
is here to help you get better at comedy
Faster by interviewing comedians like
Brandon Smiley so let's keep in touch
leave an iTunes review if you want us to
keep comment on those charts and we will
see you next Monday
oh
[Laughter]
foreign